[Music]
i'm jesse from the buzzfeed food team
and today i'm going to be testing six
celebrity mashed potato recipes to find
out which one is actually the best i
have recipes from gordon ramsay the
pioneer woman tyler florence i nagarin
oprah and for a little bit of fun i have
a recipe from two chains this morning i
peeled all the potatoes and i measured
everything exactly as the recipes state
to find out which one has the best
recipe and just level the playing field
i picked my winner but i'm gonna have
three of my friends pick their winners
today in a taste test which celebrity
has the best mashed potatoes well let's
get mashing
oprah uses both red and idaho potatoes
to make her mash she uses a ton of
butter to make them super creamy she
uses a hand mash to make them nice and
smooth seasons them up and adds her
secret ingredient an entire bottle of
horseradish so we know these potatoes
are gonna have a kick to them
[Music]
these look heavenly a lot of like a
potato skin in here there's something in
here it smells like
horseradish there's definitely some soul
in these mashed potatoes i don't hate it
but i don't like it next up is the queen
aina garden under garden uses plain old
boiling potatoes to make her mash she
covers them in water and sauce them so
the water seasons the potatoes from the
inside out she mashes them through a
food mill which is an old school of mash
in them and pretty labor intensive but
they come out nice and smooth
once they're mashed she adds good butter
and milk mix that in until they're
creamy season them and adds her special
ingredient sour cream
these look very classic very your
regular plain jane mashed potatoes i
think it's just salt pepper butter
mashed potatoes i don't like the taste
texture-wise is very fluffy that i like
is creamy but it's very simplistic
up next we got gorn ramsay with his
recipe for champ which is just a fancy
word for mashed potatoes with green
onions
he uses round red potatoes and cuts them
into chunks so they cook evenly
he presses them through a potato ricer
to make sure they're super creamy and
there's no chunks left over once mashed
he adds butter and an entire bunch of
green onions he mixes those in and adds
milk and cream that's been heated in the
pan he seasons with salt and pepper and
that's it to me it seems like a [ __ ] ton
of green onions definitely not the mash
to eat on a hot day what a beautiful
smell smells like my grandma's purse
gorgeous okay
the onion and scallion is like
overbearing oh there's like some heat to
it what's really interesting about this
is that the scallion is not only adding
so much aroma but it's adding texture
it's adding a crunch to it the chives
work so well here but the parsley is
just like what what are you
tyler florence starts with yukon gold
potatoes and does something crazy with
them he covers them in milk and cream
adds smashed garlic and herbs and boils
them directly in that mixture he strains
them out but saves the cooking liquid to
thin them he adds that
mashes them with the hand master until
smooth adds butter and a ton of whole
grain mustard he seasoned with salt and
pepper stirs all that in and calls it a
day
hella yellow i love these little seeds
they give it this little crunch i feel
like it tastes a little mustard i don't
hate it i mean it's like if you took
like german potato salad it made it
mashed potato salad
up next is a wild card two chains he
gets a little fancy and uses yukon gold
potatoes and leaves half them unpeeled
to give it a nice texture he cooks them
in salted water until tender and drains
them he adds sour cream parsley butter
and garlic that has been boiled in a
separate pot he mashes it all together
until smooth and seasons with salt
pepper and even more garlic this time
garlic powder
you can tell he's all about aesthetics
because he garnishes with even more
parsley on top
this looks like a classic mashed potato
recipe
it's good i want a little bit of salt
but it's good but it's still super
fluffy and then the garlic like really
like smacks you in the face makes my
hair go like this
finishing up the competition was the
pioneer woman with the recipe straight
from her ranch she recommended using
russets or yukon gold potatoes so i
decided to be fair and just use both she
boils them strains them and mashes them
in a hot pot to get rid of any extra
moisture she adds a ton of butter an
entire package of cream cheese half and
half and mashes that all together she
seasons with pepper and seasoning salt
but no regular salt and she finishes it
with even more butter
this is so buttery you can see it on top
it's delicious it's so good midwestern
mashed potato deliciousness
my favorite mashed potatoes of all the
celebrities was definitely oprah's it
was very creamy the texture was good it
had some like salad potato in there
gordon's is my mashed potato
first prize winner
the two freaking chains dude if you're
single and i happen to be single i'll
help you find someone cause that does
that i don't like him but the potatoes i
do i really do i was brought in as the
tiebreaker to determine which of these
mashed potatoes is the best
that's good the skin is in there got a
nice little flavor
i like the garnish on the top of this
this is delicious i love mashed potatoes
i just found out that my favorite mashed
potatoes are made by gordon ramsay and
there you have it the winners gordon
ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes